anti-vaccine protests in canada are now
having a major impact on the auto
industry they're disrupting trade and
forcing some manufacturing plants to
slow production now the department of
homeland security warns a similar convoy
might pop up near the super bowl chris
van cleave reports
for a fourth morning in a row canadians
protesting vaccine mandates are blocking
traffic on the ambassador bridge it
functions as a vital link between the
u.s and canada america's largest trade
partner
now there are new concerns similar
protests could soon caravan across the
u.s in a bulletin to law enforcement the
department of homeland security says it
received reports a convoy of truckers
plans to potentially block roads in
major metropolitan cities and severely
disrupt transportation
the dhs alert says the convoy could
begin sunday in los angeles the site of
the super bowl gathering truckers as
they travel across the country possibly
reaching washington d.c on march first
the same day as the state of the union
any layer of complexity complexity you
throw on to a major event like the super
bowl it creates potential problems
potentially they could keep certain
roads open only to emergency vehicles
protests are already impacting auto
manufacturing on both sides of the
border ford gm toyota and chrysler's
parent company are all experiencing
production disruptions traffic is being
diverted to another bridge some two
hours north where trucks are waiting up
to four hours to cross it just keeps
going on and on the longer this persists
canadians that depend on jobs that rely
on trade will be impacted
and there is no clear timeline for when
this could be resolved there is mounting
pressure in canada to get this bridge
back open particularly now that it's
impacting the auto industry the way it
is as for super bowl sunday the former
sheriff you heard in our story there
said there is a contingency plan in
place for a mass protest that could
include mass arrests but
big rigs are not something that can be
easily and quickly moved vlad
all right chris reporting from detroit
thank you